there is so much to be learned from
poker and games in general
so i've tried to transmute poker into my
mission of understanding the games that
we're naturally participating in and i
think that game theory and the systems
thinking that's so necessary to success
has so many wider applications you think
about decision making you think about
human performance being the person who
can show up and perform every day
thinking about understanding yourself
understanding your own psychology i
realized through working with other high
performers in business and investing
that so many of the things that i had to
develop in myself instrumentally to
become one of the best poker players
translated to a number of fields as well
so i think of poker as almost my sandbox
or my lens for understanding how can we
achieve the ambitious things we set out
to achieve how can we
you know find a life of freedom and
purpose it's always been my
avenue of understanding
what are some of those skills that you
think are sort of cross-applicable from
poker to other areas of life i guess i'm
kind of thinking the ones that someone
watching this or listening to this would
be able to
kind of yeah would be applicable to them
because i imagine knowing how to count
cards is not one of them but i'm sure
there's a whole world of others
sure i'll share one that's probably my
favorite lesson from poker so we have
this concept called expected value and
you know as any gamer knows you start to
abbreviate things in a lot of terms so
we're just always ev it's like plus cv
minus ev so like something has expected
value something doesn't have expected
value so
small bit about math right you don't
need you can't get advantage from the
math but you have to know it expected
value is on average
what is the expected outcome from doing
this so way to calculate it is for each
instance it's the
how good it is multiplied by what
percentage is happening
so you say like flipping a coin right
fifty percent chance of had certain
chance of tails it evens out yeah but if
you say something more like all right
i'm going to
pay you two dollars if it's heads and
you're gonna pay me one dollars if it
tails okay two times fifty cent two
times fifty percent is one
plus
one times fifty percent is fifty so
every time we do this i bet a dollar
expect to make 1.50 so i'm making 50
cents every time we do it right so
expand this out every action that we
take has an expected value you have some
form of risk and some form of reward and
so the way that my brain works through
just getting punched in the face so many
times in poker is just like
is the ru is the risk worth reward or
like all the options available to me
what has the highest expected value and
so that's anything like okay what
restaurant am i going to go to what am i
going to order at that restaurant who
should i go over and talk to this person
should i reach out to this person that i
want to talk to thinking about okay well
what's the upside of this what what do i
what am i putting at risk what are the
other things that i could be doing
instead the opportunity cost and once
you start to just wear this idea of
expected value like close you realize
that everything is a bet you talk to
people about poker be like oh well i
don't gamble it's like okay well
everything you do is a bet every action
that you take you're saying like this
step forward gets me somewhere and so
you're decomposing all your actions into
like is this a good bet
and that's why the way i've sort of seen
my life is just i'm taking all these
tiny
calculated risks that i expect will get
me one step closer to where i want to be
hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day